Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome back to our series on prosthodontics.
Like all my videos, I'm going to be focusing on the highest deal things you need to know
for the board exam.
So in this video, we're going to talk about jaw relations, occlusion, and how we capture
this information and use it to treatment plan prosthodontic cases.
So first, it's important to talk about how to capture the arrangement of teeth in a
patient.
In a future video, I'll talk about all the different impression materials out there,
but allogenit is certainly the most universally used material, excluding digital impressions,
and the material of choice for diagnostic casts.
So we're going to talk about it for just a few minutes here.
And casts are basically molds of your teeth, and they look a little bit like this.
So allogenit is made up of several components, sodium or potassium salts of alginic acid,
which react chemically with calcium sulfate to produce insoluble calcium alginit.
There's this component in the alginit powder called diatomaceous earth, which adds strength
to the impression material, and tri-sodium phosphate controls the setting reaction.
That's probably the only compound I would commit to memory for the board exam in case
that comes up in a question.
So these three bullet points all have to do with the alginit powder, which you then mix
with some preset amount of water, depending on the alginit you're using.
And you want to make sure you have enough bulk of your impression material, because more
bulk means less susceptibility to unwanted dimensional changes.
So the alginit should be sufficiently thick in order to capture the anatomy of the patient's
teeth accurately.
That's incredibly important for the purposes of taking an impression.
So depending on what impression material you're using, about two to three minutes generally
is the amount of time that you'll have to keep that impression tray seated in the patient's
mouth before the impression material sets, and then at which point you can remove that
tray from the patient's mouth.
Next you would pour that impression within about 15 minutes.
By pour the impression, I mean you mix a special powder and water together to make a stone
paste that we literally pour into this impression, and it hardens to form the moulder cast of
these teeth that I showed before.
And then within 30 to 60 minutes, we can actually separate the casts from the impression and
then throw away the impression, leaving just these casts that we can study and use in some
of the steps that I'll talk about later.
Alright, so one of the central concepts I'm going to be talking about in this video is
a concept called Maxillow Mandibular Relations, or MMR for short.
So let's break down this term.
Maxillow is of course referring to the maxilla, or the upper jaw and its teeth, and mandibular
referring to the mandible, or the lower jaw and its teeth.
So MMR is all about the relationship between the upper and lower jaws and their respective
teeth.
And there are basically two main relationships in which the maxillow teeth and mandibular
teeth can be related to one another.
And these are CR and MI, and we'll talk about both of these right now.
So CR is centric relation, that's what it stands for, and the definition of CR is this
first bullet point here.
So CR is the position in which condyles articulate with the thinnest A-vascular portion of their
respective discs in the most anterior superior position against the articular eminences.
So that's a lot going on there, that's a lot of words.
And if you could commit this to memory eventually, it would be fantastic, because this definition
is just a perfect representation of what CR is.
And it does appear on the board exam, and knowing all of these things about it is very,
very important.
But even better would be to really understand what it all means.
So I underlined and bolded condyles, because that's what's important with the CR relationship.
So here in this picture, we have, of course, a condyle, and the jaw would come down here
into the right.
And up here we have the glenoid fossa, and then the articular eminence coming down this
way.
So this is the temporal mandibular joint complex, and all of the things that it contains.
So going back to the definition here, I'm going to get my pen ready.
It's talking about the condyles articulating with the thinnest A-vascular portion of their
respective discs.
So of course there are two condyles, one on the right and one on the left side of our
mandible, and they each are articulating with this disc here.
And so I will outline the disc with this red pen here.
So this beige-colored structure is the articular disc that the condyle is constantly in contact
with.
And the definition is referring to the fact that centric relation is when the condyles
are in the most anterior and superior position.
And that's what those arrows are referring to here.
And you can tell that this portion of the disc, in contrast to this portion and this
portion, is the thinnest portion of the articular disc.
So this is a very good representation of what centric relation looks like where the
condyle is in some ways at home or at rest, and it's in the most anterior and superior
position articulating with the thinnest portion of the disc.
Now notice I didn't mention anything about the teeth in this scenario.
And this image in fact doesn't have any teeth depicted on it.
And that's because the teeth really aren't important in centric relation.
It's all about the condyles.
So centric relation is completely independent of teeth.
And I think this is a very helpful way to think about centric relation, especially when
we contrast it to maximum intercussation, which is our MI.
That's our other big, big position in terms of maximum and abular relations.
So maximum intercussation, also sometimes referred to as centric occlusion, I want to
include that as well, has to do with the complete interdigitation of the teeth.
So this is in complete contrast to centric relation, even though they might look similar
clinically if you were just to look at their smile, and we'll talk about how to differentiate
that in a second.
But maximum intercussation is all about the teeth.
We want the teeth to be completely locked together.
So the teeth are at home, and the condyle, we don't really care about that anymore.
So whereas in centric relation, it was all about the condyle, and we were not really
concerned about where the teeth were, maximum intercussation is the opposite.
This is where the teeth are locked together, and we don't really care about where the
condyles are.
That might be a little bit of an oversimplification, but I think it really, really helps to put
this all together, big picture thinking, especially for the board's exam.
All right, so let's talk a little bit more about the distinctions between these two positions.
So maximum intercussation and centric relation, which I'll just refer to you from now on as
MI and CR, for both of our sakes, so MI and CR coincide in only 10% of the population.
That means 90% of patients have a different CR where the condyles are at rest and MI position
where the teeth are at rest, and in these 90% of people, there's actually a slide in centric.
That means where the teeth slide together between these two positions.
Now some of my earliest videos on this channel that I made several years ago cover this topic
of occlusion and Poisson's diagram fairly comprehensively.
So I'll leave links in the description for both of those occlusion videos.
Now casts of the teeth can be mounted on an articulator, which we will cover later in
this video, in either of these two positions, CR or MI.
We use MI particularly or generally when a single crown or bridge is done, and the interlocking
of teeth can be maintained before and after the procedure.
So if the patient's teeth really lock together well, and you can reliably do what's called
hand articulation, where you put the two casts together just by hand and you can kind of
feel the teeth locked together and be pretty stable in a certain position, that's when
MI could be a very good way to mount the casts, again which we'll talk about in just a second.
Now CR is used for mounting casts in nearly every other situation, and CR is so important
because what if you have a patient without any teeth, which we would call fully edentulous,
or what if there's a patient that has lots of posterior teeth missing, or with lots of
malalignment or class 3 bite issues.
CR is better to use and more reliable in these situations, and particularly thinking back
to the patient without any teeth, well they don't have an MI position because they have
no teeth, but they still have condyles, and that's what's important.
So for those patients where MI is impossible to maintain, like in complete dentures, or
we're doing a full mouth reconstruction where every tooth is going to become crown and bridge
work, CR is better to use and more reliable than MI because their teeth may not lock together
in a particular repeatable position, or maybe they have no teeth at all.
And that's just it, CR is the most reliable and reproducible jaw position of the mouth,
and that's super super important to know for all of prosthodontics, particularly for this
section of the board exam.
So what we've been dancing around so far is the concept of occlusal harmony, and I love
this analogy so much, and that's the joints, muscles, and teeth must function in harmony
much like a door in its frame.
So you can think of this analogy extending to each component of the mouth and the temporal
mandibular joint complex.
So the hinges of the door would be the TMJ.
The teeth are like the door and its frame, the frame being the stationary component which
is the maxilla, and the door being the movable component which is the mandible.
And the muscles of this complex are like the hands that you and I are using to open and
close the door.
So sometimes the door has a corner that's a little too long and the door doesn't close
all the way or the frame is bent just slightly, one of the hinges is off-kilter, or maybe
we slam the door too hard and just broke the thing.
And I just love this analogy because you can use all of those little ideas and concepts
to think about what goes wrong in a particular component of the joint muscles and teeth.
So we want everything to work together in occlusal harmony.
So one of the questions you may have is well how do you get a patient to the CR position?
I understand how to get them to MI position where their teeth lock together but the CR
part is a little bit harder to understand.
And this is where we're going to talk about it.
So if you just tell the patient to bite together that's probably going to be their MI position.
Or maybe they have several different bites that are just not repeatable and they bite
differently every time you ask them to bite together.
So the CR position may not be that patients at home position particularly if their MI
and CR positions don't coincide, remember that's 90% of patients.
So one of the most accurate methods to obtain an accurate CR inter occlusal record is with
bimanual manipulation.
And the inter occlusal record portion I'm talking about is made with either wax or polyvinyl
saloxane which is also known as PBS and it's a registration or physical capturing of the
relationship between the upper and lower teeth made with an elastomeric material like
PBS for instance.
And it looks something like this, the patient would essentially bite together into it, this
material would set and later would allow you to mount your diagnostic casts together and
ideally that same relationship.
So with the patient lying back like in this picture support the posterior mandible with
fingers and the chin with the thumbs.
And your idea with bimanual manipulation is to deprogram the jaw.
What this means is basically have the patient relax their jaw as much as possible so you
can manipulate it in your hands and you want to gently direct their jaw so the condyles
are in the most superior and anterior position because that's what centric relation was all
about.
And then once you can access that centric relation position you can swing the mandible until you
get one tooth contact.
So that's what I'm talking about and I say identify the first CR tooth contact and repeat
until you identify a consistent first tooth contact.
Because since 90% of patients don't have the same MI and CR, CR is likely not going to be
where all the teeth just lock together instantaneously.
You'll have the condyles in their centric relation position and then as you close the
mandible there might be one or two or maybe three teeth that contact first with an opposing
tooth and if you can consistently reproduce those first tooth contacts you know you're
in CR.
So that you can do a couple times and then what you do at that point the ideal CR record
would involve keeping the teeth slightly apart in the CR position and then finally taking
a record of the back teeth with that previous material so you might only capture the posterior
teeth say premolars and molars for an ideal CR because you don't want the anterior teeth
to get in the way.
So we've talked about capturing the teeth of the patient with the alginate and capturing
how they bite together with the CR/MI record but we're missing one more piece of information
before we can mount this case on an articulator and that is the face bow record.
So the objective with the face bow record is to duplicate on the articulator the relationship
of the maxillary arch to the skull and indirectly the mandible to the rotational center of the
TMJs that exists for that particular patient.
Okay so another bunch of lots of words here so let's define and simplify this.
So this is a face bow it is basically a conglomeration of a bunch of mechanical components that
make various measurements and that face bow would hook up onto an articulator here and
tell you where that maxillary cast should go relative to the hinge axis of the articulator
and there are two different kinds of face bows.
We have the arbitrary face bow which orients the maxillary cast to the skull via the external
auditory meat edus to stabilize the bow essentially the face bow is fit into the patient's ears
like earbuds whereas the kinematic face bow is a little bit more complex and it's placed
directly on the hinge axis of the mandible.
So you can think of the arbitrary face bow being a little bit less precise but more
easy to use.
So basically how I think of it is the face bow record transfers the relationship between
the maxilla and the rest of the skull from the patient to the articulator.
So we know where the maxillary cast or the upper cast is going to be positioned where
we mount it onto the articulator.
So next let's talk about articulators in the next slide.
So I love this, well I love both of these pictures actually because this one in particular
shows how the articulator functions as an analog to the human skull with the maxilla
and mandible and all of that.
So the upper member of the articulator that's this component here and this component in
blue on this image is an analog to the patient's maxilla.
The lower member which is this part here and this part in yellow is an analog to the patient's
mandible and then you have the hinge axis of the articulator which is an analog to the
patient's TMJ.
So it's really cool how this all works together.
Again the face bow record transfers the relationship between maxilla and the rest of the skull
from the patient to the articulator.
So you use the face bow to tell you where this maxillary cast is going to go.
Is it going to go a little bit forward, a little bit more back, a little up, a little
tilted or canted one way or the other?
That's what the face bow is for.
The inter occlusal record or the byte registration that we talked about previously transfers
the relationship between maxilla and mandible from the patient to the articulator.
So you use the record to mount the mandibular cast to the maxillary cast after you use the
face bow and this would be like a wax byte registration.
So you could use this once you have the maxillary cast in place from the face bow to then mount
the mandibular cast to the maxillary cast.
And then you have your mounting.
It's a physical representation of your patient's byte outside the mouth which is incredibly
useful to us as dentists and prosthodontists doing prosthetic work, doing operative procedures.
This is just something that really can't be beat and articulators and mounted cases are
so incredibly useful.
So let's talk a little bit about the different types of articulators.
So we have the non-adjustable articulator first and we're basically going to go from
the most simple form of articulator to the most complex.
So non-adjustable articulator does not reproduce the full range of mandibular movement.
Basically it opens up and down much like a door hinge.
Or as we know that the patient and their mouth functions much more complex than that.
There's a lot more dynamic movement that goes on.
And again this is sort of demonstrated in Pissalt's diagram which I talked about in my
first occlusion videos.
We know the mandible is a lot more dynamic than just opening and closing.
There's a rotation phase followed by a sliding phase and this articulator just simply can
not replicate the complications of mandibular movement.
So it falls short in that regard just a little bit.
Also the distance between the hinge and the teeth is significantly shorter in the patient.
So you can see here that the distance between you know where the teeth would go somewhere
here let's say and the hinge axis over here is much shorter than what would be in the patient.
And so that's just another shortcoming of the non-adjustable articulator.
And as a result this may result in premature contacts and incorrect ridge and groove direction
of the restorations.
So unless you're doing a very very simple case everything is mounted in MI, don't have
many concerns about premature contacts, occlusion concerns, maybe you can get away with a non-adjustable
articulator.
If you can't then much preferred would be the semi-adjustable articulator which is a notch
above that one.
So this one adds a bit more customization let's say.
It allows you to set the Bennet angle and the horizontal condler inclination or HCI.
The classic numbers to remember for the board exam are 15 degrees for Bennet angle, 30 degrees
for HCI.
So I again cover these concepts in my occlusion videos but just as a refresher the horizontal
condler inclination is basically the vertical angle that condiles move as the patient's
jaws function, the condiles slide down the articular eminences and Bennet angle is essentially
the horizontal angle as the condiles move laterally in function.
The Archon articulator and non-archon articulator are two distinct categories that we start
running into when we talk about semi-adjustable articulators.
So the Archon articulator is where the condiles are part of the lower member and the fossa
are part of the upper member.
So when I'm talking about with the condiles in this image here we can see this little
gold ball here is sort of the analog to the patient's condile if you will and that's
directly attached to this lower member which we saw as part of the mandible.
So that's pretty anatomically accurate where the condiles part of the mandibular bone and
then the fossa is where that golden ball sits.
If I can erase that writing there you can see how this silver portion with the gold slot
here would be the analog to the patient's Glenoid fossa and that's part of the upper
member so this is a loyal and accurate anatomical analog to the patient.
So that's why we call it Archon.
The non-archon example is the opposite where it's not anatomically correct and in fact
the upper and lower members are rigidly attached.
So those are two terms I would be familiar with and this one again is an example of the
Archon semi-adjustable articulator and all those the HCI you can change here and the
Benet angle you can change here so there's a lot more customization than with the non-adjustable
articulator where it's just a simple open and close hinge.
And then we have the most complex articulator, the fully adjustable articulator and this
one has even more things that you can adjust lots of things you can mess with back here
and this goes a little bit beyond the scope of this video I don't think you really need
to know how this works or anything like that.
There's this very complex tracing process involving a pantograph which is used to follow
the patient's exact border movements and again I don't think you would need to know this
for the board exam but just for completeness sake this is the most complex articulator out
of the three we talked about.
Alright so one thing I did want to mention particularly for the board exam is that casts
poured from Alginet are more accurately mounted with wax records and casts poured from elastomeric
materials like the PBS that purple material we talked about and it comes in many different
colors are more accurately mounted with elastomeric materials or zinc oxide eugenol paste.
So this is something that one of those kind of random dental material facts that I would
commit to memory for the board exam but the nice thing here is that if you pour the casts
from an elastomeric impression it's best to mount them with the same kind of material.
Alright so if occlusion is all about teeth functioning together, disclusion is where
the teeth are separating from one another in function and that's to in order to protect
the teeth from wearing and receiving too much occlusal force and potential trauma.
So let's talk a little bit about disclusion because this is really important or talking
about making prosthetic teeth and using our mounted cases in order to determine how to
build up those prosthetic teeth.
So again this slide is all about disclusion when the patient is protruding the lower jaw
forward as shown in this image here.
So these two concepts have to do with the patient protruding the jaw straight forward.
So we have one posterior determinant of occlusion and one anterior determinant of occlusion.
And these two concepts are extremely important for the board exam.
So condler guidance has to do with the condiles which are of course in the posterior portion
of the mouth.
So it is the posterior determinant of occlusion.
And this has to do with the slope of the articular eminence and it's represented by that horizontal
condler inclination that we just briefly mentioned before on the articulator.
So let me get my pen out here again and highlight for you.
This is the slope of the articular eminence that when the condyle is or when the jaw is
being protruded forward the condyle is being forced to slide down this articular eminence.
So depending on the patient they may have a different slope.
Some might be more shallow and some might be steeper.
And in a future video I'll talk specifically about all of these determinants of occlusion
because there's definitely a way that we can simplify it to remember just what you need
to know for the board exam and it's really really helpful.
So I'll definitely talk more about that then.
But there are certain things you have to remember if the articular eminence is shallower or steeper
and how that would impact the teeth that you could be restoring.
So anyway, you can think of it like this is sort of limiting the movement of the jaw
in a certain way because the condiles have really nowhere else to go but to be guided
by the articular eminence.
So that's a determinant of where the teeth are going to be touching and where they're
not going to be touching because the condiles really have nowhere else to go but use the
articular eminence as a guide rail.
Now we also have incisal guidance which since the incisors are in the anterior portion of
the mouth that's the anterior determinant of occlusion.
And this is where the incisal edges of lower incisors are being again forced to move a
certain way against the lingual slopes of the upper incisors.
So I'll quickly grab a new color and excuse my drawing here but I will draw a cross section
of an anterior tooth.
This is like an incisor with the singulum here and we'll say a lower incisor here with
a smaller singulum there.
So these are our two teeth upper and lower and as you bite together and say this lower
incisors contacting somewhere on that singulum, let us get a green pen and the patients in
say MI for instance their teeth are completely interdigitated and this lower incisor needs
to slide forward as the jaw is moving forward.
Well if the point of that incisor is here it really has nowhere else to go but to be guided
by this tooth and the lingual surface of that incisor.
It can't just break right through that incisor so you can see how this is kind of an interesting
situation where we have a slope from this tooth and a slope from this articular eminence.
They can be in harmony sometimes not and so these two determinants of occlusion again
determine where the jaw will move at what angle the jaw will protrude forward and down
as the mandible is moved forward.
And if we again go back to the amylog how all of this is related back to the articulator
we have this thing called a pin and a guide table on the articulator that we can use to
represent incisal guidance.
And I'll just mention that briefly in a following slide.
All right and just to finish up our conversation on disclusion we also have a discluding that's
occurring when the patient is moving from side to side.
So this slide was all about moving the jaw forward.
This slide is all about moving or this concept of canine guidance is all about moving the
jaw from side to side.
So when in lateral movements all posterior teeth are ideally immediately excluded as
contact occurs solely between the upper and lower canine on the working side.
So this is an ideal situation that doesn't always happen in every patient's for sure
but the ideal scenario is that when the patient is sliding one way or the other either right
or left the canines are contacting together and discluding are separating all these posterior
teeth so they don't have to feel this force.
The canines are very well equipped they have the longest roots of all the teeth and they're
built in such a way to be able to handle that stress.
So that is the concept behind canine guidance and of course the working side is the side
that the mandible is moving towards that's either right or left anterior guidance is sometimes
used synonymously with canine guidance but there's an important distinction to be had
here particularly when you're reading these terms on the board exam I want to make clear
that anterior guidance refers to both incisal guidance that was with the lower incisors gliding
against the lingual surfaces of the upper incisors that's in a protrusive movement and canine
guidance which is this lateral exclusion where the canines are only contacting discluding
the posterior teeth.
So anterior guidance because the canines and incisors together make up the anterior teeth
is all the guidance that occurs between those two units.
So I think that's a super helpful distinction there.
So as a summary during protrusive the incisal and condler guidance anterior and posterior
determinants of occlusion together provide clearance for all the posterior teeth so they're
separated as the jaw is moving forward.
During lateral canines on the working side and the condyle on the balancing side which
we didn't talk about before provide clearance for posterior teeth on the balancing side
that's the side that the mandibles moving away from.
So this is such a cool concept because as we'll talk about it's really this concept
of mutual protection where the front teeth protect the back teeth and the back teeth
to protect the front teeth.
It's just such a cool mechanism of occlusion and disclusion that is designed so carefully
with how the teeth work together.
So I mentioned briefly this idea of a guide table.
This is where this is the guide table of the articulator we were looking at before the
semi-adjustable articulator and this is a mechanical one and this is a custom one.
And I'll just talk about the difference between those really quickly.
The posterior guidance must be preserved when restorative procedures change the surfaces
of any guiding teeth.
So if you're doing full anterior crowns well that's going to affect the guiding teeth so
we want to make sure that our anterior determinant of occlusion stays consistent.
In other words if we're changing the canines we're replacing them with crowns we want to
make sure those surfaces are true to the surfaces that were there before at some point so we
can maintain canine guidance if that's what the patient had originally or if that patient
had a certain slope on the lingual surfaces of the anterior teeth and that was helping
to disclude the posterior teeth well we want to maintain that too if we're replacing those
with crowns and this guide table is going to help us with that.
So the mechanical incisal guide table gives insufficient information to reproduce the
exact lingual contours of the maxillary anterior teeth because the lingual contours of those
teeth are curved they're not straight across so the mechanical guide table can only do
straight lines whereas this one can be curved and more accurately represent the patient's
natural anatomy.
And the custom incisal guide table is made out of acrylic resin and is able to provide
this information because whereas this one we can't customize this one we can customize
to the patient's actual anatomy.
And here's this concept of mutual protection so we talked all about how the front teeth
protect the back teeth and that's in protrusive movements and lateral movements with that incisal
guidance that canine guidance that's how we can protect the back teeth from feeling all
of that wear from sliding whereas the back teeth also protect the front teeth because
the back teeth have flat occlusal surfaces and strong roots, nice divergent multiple roots
to help protect the anterior teeth from those up and down biting forces.
So it's really cool this concept of mutual protection how the front protects the back
and also the back protects the front.
Alright so that's about it for this video I'm sorry it went on for so long but I was
getting excited this is really cool information and central concepts to how the prosthodontic
world and prosthodontic treatment planning is working out there.
So just as a summary to review much of the things that I talked about we captured teeth
with Alginib and we pour the diagnostic casts, we capture the bite which is either MI or
CR with wax or PBS and with a bite registration, we capture the relationship between the maxilla
and the skull with a face bow and then with all of those information we can mount to an
appropriate articulator and then we can use that mounted case to study occlusion and
disclusion for that particular patient which can then inform how we design the prosthodontic
teeth.
Thanks so much for watching guys I really hope you enjoyed this video and we'll see you
in the next one.